Shawn how are you this morning I'm doing
wild Dan 6:00 6:30 I like it how did you
get the flinch ball t-shirt you know
it's something back in college I know
mostly during the offseason because
we're busy during the year but we'd
watch the showings on TV and then all
the church next to Brittany's desk and
the points ball one just calming eyes
you guys decide between that one and
Michael Evans broken glass now you
walked up to McLovin were you actually
nervous walking up to McLovin to say
hello at Rams training camp no I wasn't
nervous I uh you know I've watched the
show and say hello Lenore the fan of the
show did anybody ask you about the
flinch ball t-shirt like what it means
oh yeah I mean I've had it for a few
years now so over the years I've gotten
a lot of questions about it I gotta be
honest it's kind of a difficult game to
explain to someone who who doesn't know
but I think most people you know get on
board punch balls pretty quickly
have you played flinch ball I have
played a lot of times you know mir-1 my
teammates organ shake it out to set out
to practice early play a quick game of
football but we did play with a football
I don't know regulation match point I
like that now we have we have some more
t-shirts that we'd be happy to send to
you if you'd like more Dan Patrick show
t-shirts we'll send those own of course
I'd appreciate that
now are you XL or double XL correct okay
to X all right then we'll we'll send out
a shipment of t-shirts there how is it
dealing with Hard Knocks having those
cameras there and how often are they
there they're here all the time I mean
really really every every day every
meeting every practice you know I think
at first I was a little unsure what it
was gonna be like but I think as it's
gone on you know honestly kind of stop
noticing them and yet you said you know
I think it it's a good thing for the
team in general I
you know I do think it takes a little
bit of getting used to you know they
have these are a lot of cameras in our
meeting rooms and when you start walking
around they start following you so it's
a little it's a little different but
it's doing good for the team and and and
I've been happy with it so far but you
know you get used to being around I
guess can you have a private
conversation yeah you can I mean and
most of the time they let you they let
you know if you're gonna be miked up and
you know you know that your meeting room
you know is being filmed and has
microphones in it but honestly it's it's
gone to the point now and granted we're
pretty late in training camp but it's on
the point now where you honestly just
kind of forget that you're three than
there and everybody can just be
themselves
what are your realistic goals at that
position given who's in front of you you
know I just want to keep playing the
football I mean I think they're really
since okay started in April and then
going all the way through training camp
and into the preseason I think I've been
playing really well and I think the only
thing I can really control is is my play
and I think I've been been doing well in
that department you know it's curtains
expectations honestly I just try not to
really really have any I mean who knows
what you know what this season or future
seasons can hold for me but all I know
is that if I keep playing good football
you know good things gonna happen you're
a competitive guy I mean you put up big
numbers in college you know you're a
third round draft pick like you have to
feel like you're everybody's good as
what Jared golf or Case Keenum are don't
you well you know what I certainly think
I you know I can be the starting
quarterback in this league I mean I you
know obviously I'm teammates with this
case and Jared but I certainly feel like
and I can help this team a lot as a
starting quarterback there's no doubt
about that I mean I I think like you
said as a competitor you always want to
be in the game and you want to be
playing and I'm certainly no different I
think I have what it takes to start and
help the team but you know all I can
worry about right now like I said is
just playing good football whatever
opportunities I'm giving you know at
this moment and if I keep playing good
football you know hopefully more
opportunities will come
Oh certainly what I want and you set up
the rookie - you took advantage of golf
when you did didn't you say you know
like I can hit the goalpost
right a hundred bucks you know you took
off of him you said yeah
you said he money I mean he wanted to
hit it and he challenged me so I had to
answer the call no you did we're talking
to a Sean Mannion the Rams backup
quarterback a superfan of the Dan
Patrick show I want to see how well you
know this show all right so I'm gonna
give you three questions and they have
to do with the dance and they're not
easy but if you listen to the program as
much as you say you do then you should
be able to get these all right okay all
right all right seat no Connor played
Little League baseball what was the name
of his Little League baseball team well
done
Wow Paulie did not get off the bench for
his grade school football team hey you
don't even have to give me the nickname
just just the town Paulie played grade
school football
oh come on dammit I know I know the
nickname it's the Glenwood Cougars I
didn't know it either here's the last
one
Todd Fritz is favorite movie of all time
Fritz YZ favorite movie of all time is
oh wow you are a super fan that is great
three for three I didn't even know all
the answers to those Sean we're gonna
we're gonna
I'd like to sponsor your clipboard could
we put a dam Patrick show logo on the
clipboard or a visor is there something
we could do Shawn we could be part of
the Rams yeah I want you to start before
you put down the clipboard but if we put
a Dan Patrick show logo you know I'm not
for sure all right and here's the thing
when you win a Super Bowl
I would hope when you take off your
shoulder pads that you have a Dan
Patrick show t-shirt
McLovin s broken glasses or a flinch
ball something like that so whenever
that happens I hope that your your
flying the colors of the Dan Patrick
show no question dad no question I love
it
hey Shawn good luck the rest of training
camp during the regular season and will
send t-shirts out to you oh thanks for
having me on all right then Shawn menu
our new favorite quarterback the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience